welcome back to another episode of code
vlogs well of course we're still
figuring things out but i've got a few
new little demos in here and i've just
been testing out my model cases
basically
so uh yeah that's nothing new there just
a spinny static model okay we'll talk
about this
okay don't get scared halloween's over
we'll talk about it
and this guy now loops when he goes too
far he's gonna snap back okay i got it
set a little weird but whatever i just
quickly did it we also have this
flashlight here i've been playing around
with blender and also just making sure i
know how to
scale stuff so got a little im gui
integration here for
just testing this out really
position scale rotation can make sure
they all work
as expected and they seem to so that's
just another thing
okay
let's talk about what's on the screen
for now first of all let me get rid of
this flashlight that gets in the way
all right well we got some weird
snapping issues that i need to resolve
with the camera when you move in and out
of this inventory mode but it doesn't
really matter it's just part of the
example project so this lady i was
testing out loading a bunch of models
because as you can see there's
some errors like look at this guy's hair
he's got like his body texture for his
hair which is not it's not supposed to
be like that obviously so there's
something a little wrong there and
this chick is another animated model and
she is actually moving her feet down
there i think i don't know something's
really weird with
her though um
so i've got to sort out the model loader
i got to analyze things like this static
guy works fine he's got a hair problem
oh that's really weird when you go
inside his face oh creepy all right
this
model doesn't seem to load fine so i've
got some things i need to walk through
so uh that's an animated prop if i had
her it's just a normal prop
but i can do multiple animated models so
basically what i'm doing right now
is i'm learning more about making my own
models and testing out scenarios okay so
it's the animated model that's different
if i load her up with my normal model or
the static one without bones and stuff
she's fine
so i've got to go through what i'm doing
in my animation stuff because
clearly i've got a few errors and i bet
if i load him up in my normal intuition
he probably won't
do anything to too weird
so we can test that out i'll just put it
up here well let's make a copy first and
i should probably change these snappings
to something better like his z location
let's make uh oh should be negative 600
b is starting point and let's make this
a little bigger it'll just walk a little
further no big deal and
yeah let's make a copy of this that's
static
and i just want to see what he does in
that case
um
yeah we'll put it in a starting position
so there's just going to be one that's
statically there
oh that threw an error so it didn't
actually compile we need a different
name
just anything to test it out real quick
all right so
we go have a look at what he looks like
with lighting and stuff and there he is
he's right there
still some issues with the textures
looks like his hair is probably a
separate texture i must not be loading
it correctly or something and there are
just some
once you get a further a far enough
distance i don't know if this is an
opengl or texture thing but you get this
like flicker in the distance you see
that even in most modern renderers a
little bit so i don't know if that's
something i can really fix this
level is scaled pretty largely
but
yeah his hair doesn't load there she
looks fine
she's probably even got
different kind of textures on her
this guy looks fine
this guy does not
um
and there's a smaller version of him i
guess i didn't increase the size of him
or anything this guy scaled up a little
bit to fit better
but he doesn't have lighting on him
obviously
so we've got a little more work to do
and just getting this
shader stuff straight now but
we're still on a pretty good path
and
blender let's talk about blender so i am
trying to
make this little flashlight here and
export the textures and i'm still trying
to figure out what i'm doing exactly
it's just like a i don't know just a
quick thing i made just to see to play
around with textures because obviously
you want like a different one on the
lens a different one for the button up
here
and then i would wanted just like a flat
glossy black for the rest that's got a
little metallic shine and i was learning
how to export textures
doesn't seem too hard was rather
involved i might just make a tutorial on
it eventually but i've got a little more
learning to do before i feel comfortable
doing that so i did export some of the
textures
and i think if i just
modify
let me find this here
the material file on it oh that's uh
something else
here we go because i think what i got to
do is like
math
kd and i can make this automatic of
course and then i need
whatever i saved these textures as
i think i turn
this black one into oh i gotta look
here we go texture test one
texture s
or just test
what is it a png
png yeah okay
trying to get them both on the screen at
once
and uh yeah blender should handle this
i'm not uh well i know what i need to do
to make blender handle it but i'm not to
that step i'm still figuring out a few
more things but essentially
we bake the texture
and then we tell it to use that texture
so let's see if the flashlight looks
better here
uh flashlight do you have textures there
it is
all right i got to get this thing
shrink uh let's scale it up a tiny bit
there we go
actually looks half decent there
and uh yeah texture seem to bake okay
but they're not perfect i forgot to
unwrap some of them so some of them are
like scaled smaller than they should be
but yeah that's where we're at we're
making some waves
definitely going to be working on this
model loader a lot but i was basically
getting in a bunch of test cases and
yeah learning more about all these
models and figuring out kind of exactly
what i want to do ideally in a perfect
world any good model or any properly
exported model it'll handle no matter
what path it is whether
or what type it is
like fbx objs it should handle all of
them and it should basically
you know not make it hard for the end
user nobody wants to import their model
into an engine and then just have it
look all wacky and they have no idea why
but it looks like the way i currently
have this that's going to happen in some
cases so
yeah we got our next goal
and it's uh
i think what i'm going to do is just put
a bunch of different cases in here and
see if i can get them to all work
correctly
i guess it wouldn't be a bad idea to
give a little pop-up and ask about what
you want to import or what you want to
do
there she is animated so if i can get
her also animating correctly and the
textures fixed
and then lighting on these animated
models will be in pretty good shape
that's basically where i'm at and now
that i know how to make my own little
programmer art models
and baked textures
i'm starting to feel a little more
comfortable designing my own stuff
and uh yeah we're looking pretty good
i'm not sure what else to say other than
next steps after this model is all
figured out and well we've got i am
gooey figured out too so that's nice
we're ready to go there i think the next
thing is going to be
oh boy we got a lot i don't even know if
i want to get to the next thing but once
i finish everything that's broken here
on the screen currently i think it's
time to move on to
shadows
and physics so maybe version seven the
one after this one we've been working on
forever
is going to be all about shadows and
physics because uh yeah i definitely
want to be able to get physics going on
these models
as they're animating if i want to turn
them into ragdolls or whatever i need to
figure out all that too
and there's also uh inverse kitimatic
stuff i don't think i'm quite i got my
eye on that yet
but uh that won't be too far down the
road either i don't think so yeah we're
really coming along here all right
thanks for watching see you next one bye
now
[Music]
[Music]
you